des vitres brisées plus loin une église
endommagée autant de stigmates laissés
par la frappe de missile russe survenu
mercredi sur zaporigia trois
établissements scolaires 5 bâtiments
résidentiels et des magasins ont
également été endommagés dans ce
quartier résidentiel
j'étais en train de préparer à manger
je sais dans mon couloir à ce moment-là
l'explosion à retenti mon mari et mon
enfant étaient dehors si j'avais été
dans la cuisine je pense que j'aurais
été blessé
d'autres ont eu moins de chance nombre
d'habitants du quartier sont saisis par
l'émotion
les équipes de secours ont travaillé
tard dans la nuit pour retrouver dans
les décombres les victimes de l'attaque
dans son allocution quotidienne le
président ukrainien vole au-dimir
Zelenski a rendu hommage aux victimes
les terroristes russes sont encore
frappés vaporidja
il y a des victimes
certains ont été blessés
j'adresse mes condoléances aux familles
et proches endeuillé
zapporizia se trouve à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres seulement de la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'Europe sous
contrôle russe depuis l'an dernier
qui avait Moscou s'accuse régulièrement
de mener des attaques toutes proches de
la centrale